it is almost all of the above jQuery
does add a few kilobytes the size of
your pages so it will add a minut amount
of time to your page loads but given all
of the syntactical sugar you gain most
developers are more than happy to add it
to their websites on a personal note I
want to add that while I was making this
class my opinion about jQuery actually
changed a little bit I generally tend to
use just plain old JavaScript to do Dom
manipulation because I don't want to add
the extra kilobytes to my pages but
honestly after doing the research and
developing this class and spending more
and more and more time with jQuery it
really is pretty awesome so I'm gonna go
ahead and draw a smiley face here it's
an ugly smiley face but that's what I'm
feeling right now so good job for
finishing guys